and the subject of today's video will be
Cronus and Cronus for those who just
listening there are two different
spellings of the name up on the screen
that refer to the two different deities
now whenever I discuss Cronus I
generally refer to him as the Titan of
time and the harvest and the response I
get quite often is am i confusing the
Titan Cronus with the primordial deity
of the same name and my answer is always
the same no I'm not but I can see why
there is some confusion so it's about
time I made a video where I explain and
clarify the differences and similarities
between the two or at least try to so I
guess we can start with what we already
know that one was a Titan and the other
a primordial the real difference between
the two comes in the religion itself we
know that over the years there were many
different types of Greek religion in
different regions and the primordial
Cronus comes from orphism the religion
of the Orphic Greeks their iteration of
Greek mythology is quite similar but
they do have some differences in their
details as well as an entirely different
idea as to how the world came to exist
so the Orphic people Cronus was the
primordial God of time he was also a
serpent with three heads the head of a
man a bull and a lion but that's just
weird and not too relevant to what we're
discussing today he was also the son of
Fanny's the first ad to hatch from the
cosmic egg the first ruler of the
universe who would then pass the mantle
down to his daughter NYX and in turn her
son Uranus definitely quite a different
creation story than were used to to make
things even more confusing Cronus was
sometimes equated to the Titan
affion the first Titan king who the
actual Titan Cronus wrestled off the
throne rather than taking the throne
from his father Uranus at times he was
even referred to as Cronus Aeon or just
a on so you can see how confusing this
is all starting to get and over the
years the
Rican Roman poet seemed to agree the
likes of pindaris Nonna's and Cicero saw
Cronus the father of time and Cronus the
father of Zeus as the same deity the
primordial iteration was essentially
dissolved into the Titan and he became
the god of time and the harvest what was
once the primordial God of time was now
referred to as a on the personification
of eternity so when I and others refer
to Cronus as the Titan of time no I'm
not confusing him with the primordial
Cronus because they essentially just
became one deity when the Orphic
tellings of greek mythology were phased
out and slowly replaced let's not forget
that the oldest accounts of Greek myth
that we have come from the Mycenaeans
and they believed Poseidon was the
signature deity the head of their
Pantheon but no one really refers to him
as the ruler of Olympus today because
their ideas were taken and dissolved
into newer iterations of the religion if
you are someone who distinguishes
between the two then surely you also
prescribe to the Orphic idea that eros
was the primordial God of love and not
the son of Aphrodite do you then just
dismiss the whole story of Eros and
Psyche or do you believe that there are
two Eris's which again only serve to
make things more confusing essentially
what I'm trying to say is Greek
mythology had many different phases of
belief that over time were replaced by
new ones and if you start to cherry-pick
from different periods in time and try
to put them together you end up with one
big incoherent mess and Greek mythology
to begin with in its most refined state
is already an incoherent mess so
sometimes it is just easier to accept
that over time beliefs did change and as
a result certain gods and goddesses
disappeared or they will merged into
something else
so in conclusion is Cronus the Titan god
of time yes but there are also of course
are the deities associated of time just
as you have hundreds of deities
associated with the sea or death not
just Poseidon or Hades
neither idea is incorrect it just comes
down to what you believe
hopefully my tiny chimp brain has been
able to piece together some kind of
coherent line of thought that you guys
now understand but maybe I've just
confused you even more I don't really
know anymore
let me know what you think in the
comments below as always I've been your
host mythology in fiction explained
[Music]
[Music]